brothers and sisters and dear friends
i've been meaning to do this video for
the past two weeks since my ishmael
passed away but due to a few other
reasons i didn't get a chance to do it
subhanallah um but anyways i want to
share three things from brother
ishmael's life that we all can take an
amazing lesson from number one one thing
that i saw in him i've never met him in
person never met him in person but when
i saw him it's as if i feel like i can
vouch for him like usually um
said that don't vouch for anyone unless
you've traveled them you've
done business with them and you've lived
with them but with brother ishmael is as
if i could vouch for him i could say you
know what brother yeah you know i vow
for this brother where did that come
from i don't know what i do know is from
the videos that i saw of him be it
videos that he's done before before his
cancer after that you can see the guy
has truly internalized islam and this
reminds me of the prophet salallahu why
because
before he received wahi
he had a reputation amongst the quraish
what was his reputation trustworthy
truthful
loyal
somebody of excellent character i mean
good manners soft in speech
not backbiting others not talking about
others
this was something he embodied
this is before he received the wahi just
imagine how much more beautiful and
character did rasulullah
increasing when the he was given to him
and brothers and sisters one lie
sometimes we look at people who are
non-muslim and we'll be like wow if this
person came to islam it'd be amazing i
saw this in ishmael even though i didn't
know i saw his excellent character the
question i want to ask is how many of us
could come and say you know what i am
known as not being a backbiter or i'm no
one i'm known as not being someone
that's oppressed others one lie i
believe i don't think anyone can come
and say ishmael wronged me or ishmael
came and you know really trying rest me
never i truly believe this looking at
his character the way he carries himself
in conduct
we judge like like um said before we
used to judge by what used to come down
now we just from us apparent we look how
can we think
that a brother like ishmael would be
someone that is wrong mothers no that's
one thing that i saw in this adab in his
character and that is the reason why
when you look at the self that they will
spend tremendous amount in
adeb before they studied knowledge yeah
they would truly internalize what good
ada is that's why the prophet peace be
upon him said two of the things that are
going to behave on their judgment is
and he said i came for nothing but to
perfect good characters good character
i saw that rather ishmael and that's one
lesson that i take from his life number
two i want you to guys to watch this
video inshallah
in this video he's done a podcast with
brother faison look what he says
if somebody's faced with a
life-threatening disease right
your priorities change
in a heartbeat i mean i've always tried
to be somebody striving for paradise but
i'm on overdrive right now and
oftentimes people don't understand that
i'm trying to get to paradise i don't
know the next time i'm going to get the
call to say it's spread it's in your
lymph nodes now it's spread to your
lungs it's spread to your kidneys it's
spread to this part that's the cloud
that i got over my head so i could
choose to be like oh gosh what or i can
say you know what if allah was for it
happened it's gonna happen i can't
control that let me just focus on those
aspects of my life that i can control if
i'm going to pass away facial it's going
to happen just like it's going to happen
to you just like it's going to happen to
every single one of them so that's not
nothing that i need to be over concerned
about what i need to be
overly concerned about is how i pass
away in what state i passed away and
what legacy did i leave on this earth
why allah subhanallah that gave me the
ability to be here now from that video
do you know what i take guys if you look
at british monarch a lot of people
usually death is and if allah blesses
you with it and i'm gonna say blesses
you blesses you with an illness that you
know okay you haven't got much time left
and you know what's really funny that we
might look to ourselves and if you think
about it somebody like brother ishmael
who's been told that he has cancer he is
in more
certainty
he's we sometimes look at him and think
okay people like that are more certain
are gonna die and whereas we think like
our death is uncertain well we are more
in uncertainty we should be more than
uncertainty than ravish my wife because
brother you can die any second of
anything at least brother ishmael has
been told that he has a disease yes that
might kill him would she already she
already knows he was going to die like
generally even if he didn't have the
disease he already acknowledged that
every soul is going to taste death but
for him now he knows it can happen yeah
but we as individuals who might be
healthy now you do not know you should
be more uncertain when can i die you
should be more prepared for that day now
what's amazing about ishmael the second
point which i learned from his life is
that he is basically when he first he
didn't need death as a reminder to turn
back to allah because brother ishmael
was working in the path of allah and
seeking knowledge way before this way
before to show sincerity and i'm not
seeing those who get afflicted with
illness and turn to allah are less i'm
not saying that but i'm saying that he
turned to his lord knowing that death
can come any time way before cancer came
to him way before cancer came to him
that's why his attitude when cancer came
to him was profound he acknowledged he
said look if it's meant to be yes like
anywhere any of us can die we are going
to die but he said the priority is what
in what state i die
how many people who are diagnosed with
an illness life-threatening illness they
go into this realm of why me why is
happening but i wish this i wish i could
live which takes me on to the next video
in the next video look what brother
ishmael says ultimately right now
all i want is allah to be happy with me
that's my like
if i had like a million things going
through my mind
that'll be at the top of the list i just
want a lot to be happy with me
i want a lot to be happy with me
and i want forgiveness that's it
two things happiness and forgiveness
this is like my advice to you guys
[Music]
allah adam some of you people that you
might be in my situation and i just
don't know
some of you might be fit and healthy
some of you might be practicing some of
you might not be practicing as much as
you probably
wish you would
whether you're older than me or whether
you're younger than me
take this advice from your brother where
from your little brother or from your
older brother
take this advice from your brother
right now how i feel
i want a lot to be pleased with me and i
want allah to forgive
me well look at his priorities he goes
there's only two things that i want
allah to be happy with me and to forgive
me
how could someone like mother ishmael
how could allah not have mercy and
forgiveness for someone like brother
ishmael may allah give him the best wa
i have no doubt he's probably looking at
our state and thinking cry for yourself
well we think when someone passes away
yani ah sad poor you
somebody that truly embodies and truly
understands the reality of this
they will truly understand that death
and being tested and all this kind of
stuff is nothing but glad tidings and in
this post to muslim bilal where he's
saying ya'aki are you not jealous of me
who tell me somebody who hasn't embodied
the level of a mothman inshallah how
could anyone else say the statement how
could somebody who's on his deathbed has
got cancer who is slowly gradually
deteriorating come and say to a healthy
person ya aki are you not jealous of me
that i might see allah's promise before
you
that if that is not a true believer i
don't know what a believer is that
someone on his deathbed can come and say
are you not jealous of me and this is
the reality you know why because when we
look at a person who is dying what do we
use our akal again i mention this again
because this is the main problem that we
face which is what we look and be like
oh man look i am peak i would never want
to be in a situation but when we follow
the knuckle what
allah subhanahu wa promised and allah
says for the believing person
yes who even if the the prophet peace be
upon him said a prayer you've been
touched hit by a prick yeah
being pricked by a phone
yeah
it expects your sins
only a true believer understands and
that's why the prophet peace be upon him
said strange is the affair of the
believer
for when a calamity touches him he is
patient
and when god touches him he is grateful
to his lord
for a man to come and say are you not
jealous of me while it shows me that he
has truly embodied and understood the
hereafter
because what allah and his message has
promised is true and he genuinely
believes that in his heart that's what
allah says do not think for the martyrs
that they are dead
they are not dead they are not dead
rather they are alive with their lord
may allah make us amongst
people like brother ishmael who not only
served allah's religion who not only had
good ad
he was not only known in his community
to be helping people rather than being
known as somebody who oppressed a bug
bited and slandered people well i look
up to him
from his life to his death oksumbi i
look up to him
may allah give him the highest ranks of
jannah there are four or five ways which
i'm going to share with you guys where
you guys can help uh inshallah to give
inshallah make it
for brother ishmael inshallah the first
is number one which i'm raising funds
for brother ishmael inshallah is the
spot project he wanted to build i think
a school an orphanage and a water well
if i'm not mistaken we want to finish
that off number one the link is in the
description box below number two please
risk go to his online arabic portal for
children inshallah mysore.com his online
arabic islamic lessons maesour.com he
can get instant sadhaka
the moment you come i'm going to
inshallah
make sure that i start putting extra
effort in arabic and going to attend his
courses in sha allah to learn so that is
a sadaqajari for him his death has
inspired when brother issa died may
allah have mercy on him he inspired me
to get closer to the quran
may be a means that you have inspired me
to learn the arabic language and may you
get rewarded inshallah number one for
your kids and unlike our reporter for
children little maisoor academy.com
check that out inshallah product for
kids little masoor.com inshallah and
like i said before uh brothers and
sisters the gambian uh the project in
gambia's spot project inshallah this is
the
we can do for him instantly the link in
the description box are going to be
below please please give that for the
sake of allah sisters visit his websites
learn from there let it be an instant
sadhaka for him and may allah reunite us
with brother ishmael and beautiful souls
like him like brother isa as well may
allah bless him insha'allah may allah
subhanahu wa
give him the best in this life in his
heart in the hereafter and give patience
to his family inshallah till next time
salaam alaikum warahmatullahi